ist die sensation gelungen einiges
spricht dafür dass tatsächlich ein
mensch als toter operiert wurde und dann
nach mehreren stunden wieder ins leben
zurückgeholt wurde wurde damit zum
ersten mal der tod besiegt klicks am 20
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocken nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen immer mal
wieder passiert ist ein mensch
verunglückt tödlich in einer extrem
kalten umgebung und bleibt dort für
einige zeit tatsächlich ist danach schon
mehrfach die wiederbelebung zum teil
ohne folgeschäden gelungen und auch beim
neugeborenen mit sauerstoffmangel
während der geburt werden die babys zwar
nicht absichtlich getötet um
anschließend ihr leben zu retten aber
immerhin wird auch hier die
körpertemperatur um einige grad gesenkt
um hirn schäden zu verringern und auch
in tierversuchen wurde inzwischen
nachgewiesen dass ein gekühltes gehirn
geringere oder gar keine schäden davon
trägt allerdings sind dabei temperaturen
unter 20 grad celsius nicht möglich das
blut verdickt der blutkreislauf kommt
zum erliegen ein hohes risiko für die
patientinnen und patienten und es kommt
zu ethischen problemen bei behandlungen
in diesen tiefen temperaturbereichen die
patientinnen und patienten müssen
praktisch getötet werden damit sie so
behandelt werden können
das szenario ist jetzt folgendes werden
menschen so schwer verletzt dass sie
bereits große mengen blut verloren haben
und damit mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
auch sterben würden besteht dieses
ethische problem nicht mehr oder
zumindest nicht mehr in diesem maße
deshalb kann hier jetzt ein einmaliges
experiment gemacht werden und genau dazu
läuft eine studie am krankenhaus der
university of maryland in baltimore und
das gehe eben ethische ich sage mal
herausforderungen gibt dringt nichts
nach außen bzw fast nichts den
studienleiter semmel testament
präsentierte jetzt zwischenergebnisse
auf einer fachtagung und erklärte das
verfahren demnach wird bei diesen
meistens gewaltopfern das komplette blut
durch eine kochsalzlösung ersetzt und
die temperatur weiter auf 15 grad
celsius gesenkt medizinisch sind diese
patientinnen und patienten dann tot das
gehirn zeigt keinerlei aktivität mehr
aber dann sind für die rettung wirklich
unglaubliche dinge möglich statt nur ein
paar minuten können sie nun ein bis zwei
stunden operiert werden ihre
überlebenschancen beziehungsweise falsch
ihre wiederbelebung chancen sind jetzt
extrem viel höher komplexe operationen
sind jetzt möglich und somit wirklich
ganz andere möglichkeiten zu operieren
und das ohne die bekannte hektik aus
emergency room zum beispiel noch immer
muss es zügig vonstatten gehen aber die
zu behandelnden drohen nicht dauernd zu
sterben
sie sind bereits tot es geht darum sie
im anschluss erfolgreich wiederzubeleben
dafür wurde am krankenhaus der
universität ein spezielles rettungsteam
für diese fälle eingerichtet und in der
studie werden jetzt die von ihnen
behandelten opfer mit denen verglichen
die im selben krankenhaus konventionell
behandelt werden wenn das spezialteam
keinen dienstag sprich das team arbeitet
bereits und demnach müsste es schon
fälle gegeben haben die so erfolgreich
behandelt worden sind aber das muss man
ganz vorsichtig formulieren denn auf
nachfrage beantwortet tischer man nicht
ob das verfahren bereits erfolgreich
angewendet wurde
das werden wir erst erfahren wenn die
studie veröffentlicht wurde ist der tod
tödlich oder leben wir weiter anklicken
anschauen und klicks zum science fiction
also diesen kanal hier abonnieren ist ja
hier auf youtube kostenlos also bis dann
bleibt dran